what I like about the Jell-O is you can
you can send a ripple from one part of
the Jell-O and that Ripple will
propagate out as a Jello-O jiggle that's
right and jiggle its way across the
pineapple Bits And if you're in the
pineapple you'll feel a little jiggle as
as the wave moves
[Music]
across this is Star Talk special edition
Neil degrass Bon here your personal
astrophysicist and as usual for editions
we've got Gary O'Reilly Gary how you
doing hey Neil yeah good if you didn't
know former Soccer Pro a football pro I
guess they say that over in the UK a be
turned announcer because he's retired
and recently married Very Yes
congratulations happily married knew who
knew it would last this
long what six months not even not even
that congratulations the first six
months of marriage thank you Chuck Nice
Chuck baby hey what's happening Neil yes
I feel bad because we're checking in
with you you you're doing a comedy stint
in Aruba that's right right now so right
now you're on this instead of being on
the beach so we'll try to make this
quick for you I I I was on the beach and
left left the beach don't rub it in let
me no don't you have to make a thing out
of
it so what we're gonna do is we're g to
have a kind of a cosmic queries but like
a special edition edition of cosmic
queries and whenever we're in kind of
grag mode I need some help uh and you
know who we go to for that of course
Charles Lou Charles welcome back
hey hi Gary hey Chuck great to see you
all I was not on the beach just now not
on perfectly happy to be here with you
all hey Chuck we're of course all
envious all right so Gary you you
brought in the questions and you you
curated the questions yeah we had more
you told me we had more than a hundred
100 questions on this solicitation
yeah and um apologies up front for those
questions we couldn't get to we only
going to get about an hour's worth of
this show so we had a flash through um
and they're again yep they're all from
our patreon patrons so thank you so much
for your curiosity let's start with Gina
Martin shall we since since time as we
know moves in a straight line can we
consider time being
one-dimensional from our perspective
that being said what would it look like
if time had three iions just like space
and is that even possible
whoa GL you here
Charles we'll start with start with an
easy one right uh the the reality is uh
that we can indeed thank you for your
question uh think of time as a dimension
in fact the Rolling Stone sang a song
about that
time is a dimension right but yes the
general relativistic assess
of space time is Einstein general
relativity yes Einstein general
relativity um describes space and time
as three dimensions of space one
dimension of time now there have been
some work over the years theoretically
what if there were more than one
dimension of time and what happens is
complicated as you might imagine but the
most signific that's the answer it's
complicated next
question yes well the the simplest well
the most significant effect we would
have in our lives is on causality right
Neil as as you know we think of time
passing as stuff in the past affecting
what happens in the present and the
future but not the other way around
right if you have three dimensions of
time and you can travel both forward and
backward also left and right and up and
down in time then you don't know what
the past is by definition you have to
change your concept of what causes what
because you can be dancing back and
forth in a different dimension and
something that you thought was in the
past might actually loop around in a in
a say Grand View and wind up in our
future when you say Grand View you mean
a view from outside of those three
dimensions you have to be above you have
to be above looking down yeah above and
beyond that whole set of coordinate
system right uh String Theory you you've
seen that happen all the time too but
imagine kicking a football right a
second ago but actually having kicked
that football a second ago in one
dimension at time but kicking the
football five seconds from now in a
second dimension of time and kicking it
uh at the precise moment now in the
third dimension of time wait Dimension
where is there a dimension where you
don't kick the football not in this
configuration that's that's called the
Charlie Brown
demension I forgot about that demension
that's the Charlie Brown Dem so so child
is it just humans that see time as a
straight line and that other other
beings in other galaxies are
perceiving in a very different manner
great question at the moment since we
haven't found other beings in in other
dimension or other parts of the universe
we don't know what their brains are
structured on but the universe as a
whole has a causality to it in other
words all of the universe as we conceive
of it in Einstein's SpaceTime only has
one dimension of time if there are other
dimensions of time that we somehow can't
perceive but other creatures can
perceive and as a result the universe's
causality proceeds differently from what
we see then you build up those cool uh
science fiction ideas like arrival for
example uh which that was the Amy Adams
movie few years back I think yeah not
the other not the Charlie arrival a few
decades ago but corre the one where they
have the the linguist and the physicist
right instead of the astrobiologist and
the cryptographer yes that one where
where the the premise was if you know
your future would you want to experience
it anyway
right right yeah and the answer is yes I
want to know my future and then you want
to live it I mean even even if you knew
all the good and the bad but here's the
thing is you wouldn't live it no one's
going to live the future that they know
but you may you may ultimately cause it
by not living but no one is going to
live the future that they already know
so that's problem you're completely
right if time is onedimensional if it is
one and if time is two or
threedimensional then you don't know
maybe that's right there you
go good question
okay loved it okay Chuck you got a
question yeah here we go this is Morgan
Fisher Morgan Fisher says doctors Tyson
and Lou it's Morgan from waterl Ontario
of the perimeter Institute the perimeter
Institute very nice she says I've
wondered about this since first hearing
of the ligo experiments it is said that
colliding black holes create ripples in
SpaceTime but what's the medium there's
no air there's no water it's a perfect
vacuum so what's actually doing the
Rippling and I think she answered the
question in the question let me lead off
by saying the the perimeter Institute is
a place of study where people are asking
questions that kind of sit at the
perimeter of of established and accepted
thinking in physics math philosophy this
sort of thing and so um it's it's an
audacious construct among institutions
that are out there and if there's any
weird wild wacky idea that turns out to
be true it's more likely to come from
those kinds of think tanks rather than
from those in the establishment but so
but Charles why you take a gander at
this answer well
Morgan you have put your finger right on
the concept of the general theory of
relativity exactly space itself is a me
what Einstein explain EMP space empty
space What Einstein explained was that
our conception of space being just
vacuum or nothingness was
incomplete rather we should think of
space as this sort of giant uh either a
rubbery sheet or a flexible sort of
Jello-O that we live in that can be bent
and twisted and torn and so forth soace
jell jell space is a lot like jello
Albert Einstein showed that space is a
lot like jello you know I mean it's it's
a it's a children's okay yeah well now
what part of the universe has the
pineapple chunks in it oh Earth Earth
you see the pineapple chunks that sit in
your Jello-O mold right some of you may
have had that in things and the grapes
yeah that that's the 1960s section of
the of the jell yeah the the the things
that are floating in it are indeed Mass
uh massive particles and objects or
aerations of mass such as planets Stars
G and so forth and those
blobs cause an irritation to that
otherwise beautiful perfect Jello it it
it's an irritant that winds up causing
SpaceTime to curl in upon itself and
that's what gravities it's the Cur Jello
what I like what I like about the jello
is you can you can send a ripple from
one part of the jello and that Ripple
will propagate out as a Jello jiggle
that's right and jiggle its way across
the pineapple Bits And if you're in the
pineapple you'll feel a little jiggle as
as the wave moves across absolutely so
good job Morgan you absolutely
understand the point that Einstein was
trying to make when he developed the
general theory relativity yeah but I
don't know if that's a satisfying answer
to Morgan because what you're saying is
the vacuum is a thing so get over it
that's really I just gave the short
version of your answer well I didn't use
get over it I would say I would say
Revel in it
okay the nothingness is the thing so
reel in it enjoy make Jiggles in it so
that you can send it you know off to the
next part of the jello all right okay
let's embrace the nothingness right next
up Dennis from Indiana black holes are
we
sure Hawking radiation is coming from
the inside of the black hole or is it
just from around the Event Horizon has
an observation ever been made of a black
hole dying or disappearing stellam mass
or otherwise gentle I'm going to reshape
that question and hand it back back over
to Charles so we know that Hawking
radiation is birthed just outside of the
Event Horizon we know this okay that's
how the calculations unfold that's the
however somehow that means the mass
inside the Event Horizon
drops and I want to ask Charles Lou how
does the inside of the Event Horizon
have any clue what just happened outside
of the Event Horizon and that's a that's
a reshaping but a tuning of that
question that is a great question and
the answer still is we don't know you
see okay next question
okay but the idea is that we know
mathematically speaking Hawking
radiation comes out of any object it
doesn't have to be just a black hole it
just comes off of any object that has
mass except that from a black hole
that's the only thing that can come out
of the Event Horizon and that's sort of
the strange part of Hawking radiation
it's not that it uh is unique to black
holes but we couldn't measure it if
coming off of me for example or of Chuck
or or the Caribbean uh as much as we'd
like to uh it's a lovely place to be but
it's very very slow and very very small
what happens to create that Hawking
radiation is still a mystery Hawking
himself didn't understand it now you
know Neil right about how people often
describe Hawking radiation as maybe like
a particle getting close to the event
horizon inside and then splitting off
production into a particle and anti
particle and then the particle escapes
the rent Horizon so on so on that is
pure speculation that works
mathematically but physically it has
never been sh
and it's actually a little bit
problematic
theoretically but I'm I'm good with it
though I'm I'm I'm I'm good with if hawy
said it I'm good well so I mean and
first of all it's you're talking about
the evaporation of something like the
Mojave Desert one half grain of sand at
a time that's right which is which is
insane very slow very very very slow
very slow but
but answer my question if a black hole
can evaporate completely how does the
inside of the Event Horizon know what
happened on the outside or is the Event
Horizon just a convenience for us to
describe the edge but really the black
hole and this gravity field the black
hole doesn't maybe maybe doesn't have an
edge that the it's wherever the gravity
field is and the gravity field
collectively is the black hole and the
aing radiation comes out of the gravity
field therefore it loses Mass this is
another Frontier question a paper was
published about 20 years a ago that
suggested that mathematically Hawking
radiation could be described as Quantum
tunnel a a thing where violating what we
normally think of as the boundaries of
Any Given object you can temporarily
every once in a while get a little bit
of stuff another way to the boundary
right and it's mathematically valid so
if it is a Quantum tunneling process
then just as you said Neal that it's get
it's escaping is a shimmering surface
from which things can escape it's a
fuzzy surface that's right there's a lot
more that needs to be done to going take
a minute just to describe quantum
mechanical tunneling then we'll go to
the next question right sure so so if
you are if you're trying to get to some
destination in front of you and there's
a hill there you got to climb up the
hill and then climb down the other side
and that's a pain in the ass maybe you
don't have the energy to do that so you
never get there in quantum physics
you're a particle and there's a barrier
there you're not just a particle you're
also a wave and that wave occupies space
and part of your wave exists on the
other side of that hill and so there's a
chance you could disappear from where
you are and reappear still within your
own wave pattern on the other side of
that hill and when that happens it's
called tunneling and it did not actually
have to go over the hill and come down
the other side to get there and when it
happens it happens
instantaneously it's not a there's no
time travel for it the the wave for the
particle as we say collapses and the
particle exists outside of the barrier
now does does this remain true even for
Jack and Jill particles who went up the
hill Jack and Jill didn't go up the hill
for session pillar water they just
Tunnel right through it reared on the
other side inside of their own
waves
who's next up is it Chuck Gavin Bamber
and Gavin Bamber says hello from North
Vancouver please
visit okay sure and and then he says in
lie of a nice question I kneel down and
ask the follow oh man three puns in a
single sentence well done now I really
have to go to
Vancouver how many black holes are in
our uh are there in our galaxy compared
to the number of stars is there a fixed
ratio or is this just a random ratio so
yeah well and well we know and do you
count the one at the center of our
galaxy that's just one count yeah okay
so that does count well this is a great
question I'd like to compare our
estimates because both Charles and I
have extensive research background in
the answer to that question but we might
not end up giving the same answer so so
Charles let me hear your answer okay
here's my take uh black holes are formed
only by the most massive stars dying and
so for
every massive star that can create a
black hole at the end of its main
sequence lifetime there are millions of
other stars that cannot do that so the
maximum amount of black hole to regular
star ratio is sort of Millions to one
but then black holes have now been shown
that to it has now been shown thanks to
ligo and others that black holes can
coales and combine and create larger
black holes so that total amount can
only shrink as you continue to go
forward as big stars blow up one in a
million or less new black holes can be
formed but then as they CES they drop I
don't know what the exact mathematical
ratio of all that is but I'm guessing
that it's Millions to one or even more
rare black holes to regular Stars Neil
what's your take okay I I would say it's
not as rare as you're suggesting because
it's just a simple um integration of the
initial Mass function of stars and you
just find out the stars that are more
massive than eight eight or 10 solar
masses whatever the threshold we agree
that would be what fraction of all stars
in the galaxy have a are born with a
mass higher than that I think it's not
one in a million and the reason why I
say that is we have clusters of stars
that don't have a million stars in them
but have a high mass star that would die
that way maybe a 100,000 stars or 10,000
to 100 so I would say one out of every
100,000 stars in the galaxy objects in
Stellar objects in the galaxy is a black
hole as the consequence of the death of
this
process because when stars are made they
they're made in in in in what's a group
of star a pod or should we invent the
name cluster a a an association CL yeah
that's so boring I wanna I want like a I
want a Zoological a litter a litter
thank you a litter of stars born out of
a gas cloud um we know that the low mass
ones many more stars are made that are
low mass that are high mass it's rarer
and rarer and rarer interestingly if you
take a sheet of glass and drop it on the
ground and it shatters yeah there will
be more small parts than big Parts yes
okay a lot of things Land This Way the
initial glass function the initial very
good very good so Charles I'm saying i'
i' bet it's more like one in 100,000 not
one in million that's quite a
discrepancy between one and a million
and one in 100,000 but between
astronomers that's like the same
number they don't care they don't care
you ain't doing my
tax seriously you not
doing here's what here's what I want to
know when a when a when a stellar
Nursery produces a litter of stars does
the Galaxy then Hound the rest of the
galaxies to take one of them like
hey they're so chill you're GNA love it
we we just need some Galactic nannies to
take care of them time yeah okay so do
you see my reasoning there I do I I ask
them do you take into account very low
mass stars and brown dwarfs because if
you think a typical Sal Peter initial
Mass function right 10 solar masses uh
every Star that's 10 times the mass of
the Sun there are a hundred or more
stars 200 or more stars that are the
mass but but those brown dwarfs isn't
another term for brown dwarf a failed
star yeah
yeah so you or overing planet right
right there you go right so stank stank
oh so what all we're saying here is that
the initial Mass function of stars would
include these things that are not stars
that would come in even higher numbers
than the lowest mass stars right so
Charles is just being sort of complete
in in the in the mathematics if you're
going all the way down to the borderline
of brown dwars right then for every Star
that can produce a black hole there are
millions of objects that cannot objects
that's other
objects yeah and the initial Mass
function of brown dwarfs appears to be
flatter than that of regular stars that
can have nuclear fusion so yeah okay so
Gary both two your taxes coming up okay
then you can take the average of our
answer then you'll be bang on I'm sure
the IRS are gonna love I was gonna say
you could take the average of the
answers and you'll still go to
jail don't I'll I'll I'll stick with
someone else give me another one okay
Cameron Berg says hello Dr Tyson Lou and
of course Chuck himself hailing from
Salt Lake City and his question is is it
possible that what we call matter and
energy since the Big Bang have left a
lasting or ghost effect in the fabric of
SpaceTime and dark energy continues to
grow because the effect keeps building
as matter moves and expands into new
space so there we go Cameron Berg's
question is he saying Charles do you
think he's saying that is the is the
dark matter the absence of the matter
that has moved from its location is this
um I I feel like if I were to interpret
this question more it would be sort of
like is the residual effect of the Big
Bang what the dark energy is as it fills
space dark energy or dark matter did
they say dark energy he said Dark Energy
dark energy right right oh and so I my
response to that right Anil you can
correct me if you disagree uh the dark
energy they're very
sweet a dark energy is has been shown
clearly not to be the result of matter
and energy as we understand it including
dark matter all the contents of the
universe cannot explain how the universe
itself is expanding in a way that is
counter to that material so that
especially given the fact that dark
energy is operating in the opposite
sense that that energy matter and dark
matter would have the universe behave
that's
right hard to explain one thing with the
other when they are complete opposite in
what their forces are right the larger
the universe gets the more Dark Energy
there has to be in the current
formulation and that just means that
anything that's left over from what
exist exists in the current Universe
cannot power that additional Dark Energy
creation yeah so deal with
it you are you are harsh today I know
know I'm getting old and tired and I'm
I'm on the porch on my rocking chair you
know I'm feeling it I'm feeling I'm
older than all y'all so I get to behave
this way ah all right Chuck what you got
all right here we go so this is Emil
Forest blood who says Hey Emil from the
San Francisco Bay Area wondering about
the potential measurement of
Consciousness I believe what we call
Consciousness is an energy or Quantum
equivalent that emerges grows expands
converts like other forms of energy or
slash matter it seems that as the
universe expands Consciousness is
emerging as a natural result of the
separation of all matter from its source
over time we like need something to
measure immersing Consciousness if it
exists as some fundamental energy what
would we use to measure other forms of
energy like
Consciousness
wow honestly your your Consciousness is
not your Consciousness right now is
electrical wa wait Chuck that's the
wrong that's the wrong reply it's what
are you smoking I don't know no no no
miss that one I got hanging fruit right
there
like
many people agree with your belief
believe as you do that Consciousness
must be something physical and thing
it's a thing right there is not yet any
scientific evidence to confirm that no
if there were some way to measure it
we'd be working on it right now in fact
come from right there have been studies
right there have been studies for
example where they tried to measure the
mass of a soul or a Consciousness based
on uh the mass of your body uh or your
brain before an event and after an event
in terms of Consciousness or
unconsciousness and there just hasn't
been anything yet so that said we should
consider the possibility the more likely
possibility that Consciousness is not an
emergent form of new energy but a
emergent form of information or
organization of well-known existing
energy that somehow transcends just the
motion of photons back and forth in our
brains Neil you probably have much more
understanding about Consciousness well I
like what you said there but I I want to
add to it yeah yeah uh something that I
think it was Brian Green we were having
lunch uh couple of months ago and this
came up in conversation and it's stuck
with me ever since all right uh you want
Consciousness to have some energy field
that might be shared among people by the
way in physics
anytime something happened that we
couldn't explain we investigated it
found out what caused it exploited it
and then ran went to the bank with it so
go back in the middle 19th century
there's Faraday who puts a wire through
a magnetic field and there's a meter
over on the side connected to that wire
and it
moves and oh how does that hen it's like
what today which seems so trivial back
then was an amazing you do this this
over here and that happens over there
what what what did that and then you
find out there's current there's
something called an electron which
hadn't been discovered yet and and every
all kinds of discoveries come out of
this anytime any of us in the physical
sciences confronted something that was
behaving in a way that we didn't know or
know the cause of we investigated it
okay and so on a tabletop today
there's nothing
left that is happening where we're
saying we don't know what's
happening not on a t maybe in a particle
accelerator but on a tabletop no your
Consciousness counts as a tabletop
everybody's sitting around the table so
now here's the here's the mind-blowing
part when ligo
measures the the gravitational wave
washing over the
detector it is measuring
the movement it's it is measuring matter
at the level of 120th the diameter of a
proton and that is this wave that has
moved through the universe for a billion
years if there was something going on in
the universe affecting
matter we would see it in that
experiment if there was some mysterious
other thing oh somebody has a six sense
and they have a they have a energy field
and they got to it it would show up in
those data but it doesn't so I think we
can speak with confidence that there's
not some mysterious mind energy that's
permeating
space that that science has yet to
discover because I tell you I tell you
what if it was shaking up that atom we'd
have to account for that before we
measured the the the gravity AAL wave
and that and there was nothing there
left to encounter Charles do you know I
visited the ligo in in in Louisiana
wonderful oh what a great facility that
must be and and I happened to be there
like three weeks before they made the
announcement and everybody was like hush
liit because they thought I would just
run to social media and say no I'm way
more responsible than that but anyhow so
so when I watched the kind of stuff that
they had to subtract out of their signal
what somebody walking yeah on the ground
100 meters away there they are right
there yeah a car a mile away yeah um
there's an experiment where they measure
the gravitational constant that's it's
not ligo another one okay so they got
these torsion beams and things measuring
which is a very hard thing to measure
yeah you realize there's a mound near
that facility where if it had just
rained that mound is water logged and
they can detect the extra gravity of the
water that's in the water in the in the
in the soil yeah it's pretty amazing so
any that's my long discussion to say I I
I agree with you Charles it's not a new
kind of energy or Force it's familiar
energy configuring itself in such a way
to give us an a perception of reality
that we call Consciousness right so Neil
do we measure Consciousness as positive
and negative bearing in mind the thought
process you have it depends on if you're
into positivity or
negativity fig of that haters will be
haters that's negative cont yeah all I
know is my soul did weigh 21 gr but then
I went to Soul cycle and got it down to
about eight
oh
hello all right let's get our next one
up here this is from
B BWI and
yeah n in the south of France in in the
Olympics this is a famous Olympic story
uh in in 1992 in Barcelona or 96 in
Atlanta I can't remember which one there
was a a long-distance Runner named bhaya
and he was in this 10,000 meter race and
two other people uh someone named chileo
from Kenya another one named SCA I think
from Morocco were lapping him and he you
know this bhv was a great Runner he had
run a one number of international
competitions but he was in the way and
you're supposed to move away as as
chileo as chileo and SCA were coming
toward him SCA was like move move move
you know tell tell him take the arm and
so he finally moved away and what
happened eventually was that SCA won and
beat chelo but then the uh event judges
the judges of the event took away his
gold medal because they said that gay
had helped him by blocking chileo and it
was a it was quite the controversy and
then what happened was it was reversed
the next day upon appeal but I remember
watching that when I was a little kid um
watching like that actual event
happening on the coverage for the
Olympics and then showing St being so
upset but then Star Episode I have to do
this ready Charles why how do you know
how you
know
why do you know that okay so here we go
if we imagine a thought experiment where
two photons of light travel parallel to
each other one in the vacuum of space
the other in a fluid they both travel at
the speed of light and by definition
their respective experience of time is
zero however their relative speed being
different life moves slower in the fluid
they should actually have a different
internal clock um how can we make that
work as a question or is there a
mistake in this experiment great
question it happens all the time
actually uh and I want you to know that
that's a great thought experiment and
it's actually a physical experiment
that's been done a bunch of times it it
happens when for example subatomic
particles enter Earth's atmosphere there
say one subatomic particle misses the
atmosphere and heads off into space the
other one comes into Earth's atmosphere
and thus is going through the fluid
known as the atmosphere right the
compressible fluid of the gas over its
atmosphere just to be clear a fluid
doesn't have to be liquid or wet G if a
fluid takes the shape of its container a
gas would do that liquid would do that
so the whole field fluid dynamics the
equations are the same that apply to the
air or would apply to a liquid because
of the Dynamics that goes on for objects
moving through it continue Char yes
you're right and so uh we have shown
experimentally that the clocks for those
sub atomic particles that go through
Earth's atmosphere actually run
differently from the ones that are going
off in space and because of that their
Decay patterns are different their half
lives are different as measured by us
not in the frame of reference of the
particle so this is an experiment that
has been done and there's some famous
ones uh specifically about a particle uh
back then known as
mumons but you can we don't still call
them that we don't still call them that
we just well usually you just call them
muans or maons right oh muans sure sure
sorry muon became muan thank you yes
that's right uh so uh you can find these
experiments and show that indeed the
clocks of those individual particles
differed from those of uh their
companions that did not enter Earth's
atmosphere well by the way the clock um
so so just to be clear we're talking
about particles
traveling not at the speed of light
they have clocks right but if you're
actually traveling at the speed of light
you would not have a clock and the
question was about two photons not about
two particles oh well in that case what
you do is think about it as having no
clocks but through different media and
so the speed of light will be different
from one medium compared to the other so
you still have the same effect of
causality of the surrounding environment
having clocks clocking that
particle I hope that makes sense I I may
not have explained it very well but the
idea is that if you're thinking of time
and measuring time of that Photon which
itself experiences zero time the medium
still affects the measurement so the so
the speed of light is still the speed of
light the light is still traveling at
the speed of light it's just that stuff
around it is slowing it to less than the
speed of light lesson the speed of light
in vacuum in the right so Charles
something I learned recently I never
really thought about it yeah that when
light slows down in a medium it actually
doesn't slow down what's what's
happening is it's still moving at the
speed of light between the particles
that it encounters it just
keep right yeah yeah and then it has to
get through that particle somehow gets
absorbed reemitted or whatever if it's
coherent because if the if the glass is
translucent then it's not a straight
line through and if it's opaque it's not
getting through it all so the the the
the molecules have to be just right so
that it is transparent to the photon so
it moves through where there's no
particle at the speed of light hits a
particle that delays it because you got
to come out the other side to continue
at the speed of light isn't that just
what Chuck said it
is but I I wasn't gonna say anything
thank you I like I like your explanation
Neil I like both explanations they're
I'm I'm exerting positive
Consciousness yeah so
so the energy of the photon just had to
get in and out of the atoms or the
molecules that were in its way but
between them it's still moving at the
speed of like so it's getting it's
getting refracted it's getting diverted
it's getting yeah all that can happen
and that takes time to get in and around
the particles but that's the energy
moving not a photon as a speed of light
moving particle so so the Point Charles
is and I like I said I only learned this
very much later in life than should have
been that photons only ever actually
move at the speed of light even through
a medium
right I can I kind of see that I can
kind that's really cool so we've been
luxuriating on so many of these answers
and we hardly have any time left oh
so give me some good on all right give
me some good ones here all right let's
get a little personal then this is
Mikael bord who says uh
um hello Guardians of the Geeks
oh there's AA there's a t-shirt
Guardians of the Geeks Mikel here from
Canada who does Charles luk call when he
doesn't have an
answer oh no oh
no oh well well mik it's very kind of
you to say that but but obviously uh I
know much less than what I don't know so
uh when I need information the first
people I go to are obviously you know
much less than you don't know what does
that sentence mean it means that what I
don't know far out strips exceeds on an
infinite level what I actually do know
gotcha except what you actually know far
exceeds everybody else by an Infinity so
so so they don't even know how to ask
you a question your Infinity we're still
embedded in our own Infinity okay dude
dude that's too much thank you you're
very kind uh but when I do have a
question my go-to people mik are Chuck
Nice and Gary o riy oh you you guys may
not know this but uh actually actually
Gary and Chuck I wanted to ask you if
you had a chance to um take a look at my
question that I sent you last week where
we would use maybe use the cross terms
in Einstein's field equations to figure
out the topological constraints to A W
uh many worlds interpretation Quantum
Multiverse have you guys figured that
out yet for me and I I wrote you back
and I was like what a dumb question oh I
mean you had it right I knew it I mean
Gary I don't know if you had a different
opinion on that already no I'm I'm I'm
I'm selling that to a really high
ranking SN tanks at the moment I'm not
prepared to discuss it in
public well no when when Chuck Nice and
Gary O'Reilly do not have a question
answered for me right away um I usually
go to my brilliant wife Dr Amy Radu and
my three kids uh I am blessed to be the
dumbest person in my family I'm gonna
attest to that actually I hung out with
this kid yeah um and so I always PhD in
mathematics so yes Charles was the
dumbest one in the household it is true
by far order of magnitude so so Amy and
the kids are are really helpful and I
always go to them if I don't know
something and then if we all have to
look something up uh I always try to
find at least three different sources
with three different answers to compare
them there's so much misinformation
doesn't have your answer there and right
news right really exactly um I always
want to be sure there's so much
information out there that I estimate
that a third of it is outright wrong and
a third of it is sort of right and then
the a third of it is probably right so
I'm always trying to find at least three
sources of information people that I
trust sources that I know I actually go
back and read the papers if I can the
original sources yeah look at the actual
inform real the real question there
though Charles yeah because that that
can be flawed I can look up three
different sources and they're not
credible sources so how do you how do
you how do you vet your source to make
sure that it's credible that's what
that's what I know that is a process and
sometimes it's frustrating it takes
quite a bit of time I will look at the
source and then I will look for
references to that source and say are
those sources reliable or unreliable
what have other people said over long
periods of time very often if you uh say
type A search into any given search
engine the top 20 answers are all from
the same Source but copies of spread out
everywhere else you you have to make
sure there's Independence among that's
right so I don't hesitate to do that
it's a little bit of extra effort
sometimes a lot of extra effort to find
the answers but it's worth it it's the
way that I protect myself from
misinformation so Charles is like the
credible Hulk who all CLA with research
and documented peerreview journals
that's smash CH
dismember let's let's go jump into the
next question and we'll see because I I
think you know what it's a bit of a Hot
Topic question having look at it here
this is from Jane Von Schilling from
Scotsdale Arizona um what are the
possibilities of the combination of AI
and quantum
computers so uh is this does this
devolve into another question where is
one more powerful than the other and
what they both badass and you put them
both together that's yeah and that's the
and that's the end of us okay or the
beginning no you put it together and
that is the end of humanity say goodbye
or does is that does that solve let me
tell you let me tell you what let me
tell you what the first uh you know how
like the first computers they had well
they were numbers but they for they were
for calculations but the first thing
that came out of computer was hello all
right or the first the first from the
Macintosh from the Macintosh hello that
was the first thing that came out of the
computer the first thing that will come
out of a Quantum AI computer will be oh
you effed up now didn't you
it could be it could be but I I'll say
this right our understanding of
intelligence itself May in fact evolve
dramatically once we understand how
Quantum Computing and artificial
intelligence merge it's really neat
right now remember everyone uh Quantum
Computing is even in an earlier St age
uh in its development than regular
Computing was in the era of those first
counting machines that you were mention
Chuck we are decades away from being
able to do anything like put a quantum
computer on your desktop right maybe a
century right now the quantum computers
are cryogenically cooled they're the
size of a room and they're only able a
big Hardware issue right now not two
tiny cbits at a time to make the
calculations right but those tiny cbits
can be extremely powerful not
necessarily because a cub is the Quantum
Computing
version I have made I should have made
that clear earlier that's why I'm that's
why I'm here don't worry about it keep
talking no thank you yeah a Quantum bit
the Cubit right is a thing that depends
on staying coherent with other cubits in
order to make its calculations the
quantum coherence is extremely fragile
it requires temperatures very close to
absolute zero almost no noise of any
kind electron look at it the wrong way
much you breathe on it the wrong way oh
yeah yeah it's it's all gone so it's
really really in its infancy but it
shows a great deal of Promise in the
sense that when you put in one and one
before it puts out two there's a lot of
stuff in between which we can't see and
happens almost instantaneously and so is
that a a measure of how our own brains
work that's a great question artificial
intelligence is attempting it is our
current human attempt to use non-quantum
classical physics to mimic our brains
and our intelligence and our
Consciousness right and we're seeing
that that problem is almost intractable
to mimic a human brain uh I I saw a
YouTube video on this recently um it is
remarkably complicated we know the steps
but the hardware is seemingly
insurmountable in its difficult so those
two things put together might do it but
we still got a long way to go before
that
actually the INF manable complications
of the human mind might not be what
you'd want to emulate at all right you
want to emulate the parts of the human
mind that are capable of good things and
right and and accurate things the actual
human mind it commits violence and War
and crime and and genocide and not to
mention that just the way that we
perceive receive information is a
perception we don't actually view
information we perceive
information which is a big problem after
your senses dealt dealt with it right so
it's easy to praise the brain because we
don't understand it rather than ask does
the brain do things that we don't need
to emulate at all because we can do it
better by other means well let's first
understand it figure out what's actually
good and bad and what's causing them all
all the interconnectedness is and then
we can distill the good stuff without
worrying that that will accidentally
cause the bad stuff to happen and that's
the frontier of Neuroscience but I agree
with Chuck maybe AI will figure out how
to perfect Quantum
Computing and then how to per human
being
together will it not then as it as you
say Neil solve its own problems I mean
look at it look how long it took us from
a computer the size of a room to get to
a a
smartphone that that that timeing is
gone now that won't that won't take that
length of time for it to solve problems
that we think are impossible right now
the the issue is how we solve the
problems put your fing on the head well
within lifetimes right well think about
this if we put an AI on the problem of
solving climate change okay it might be
able to solve it in a day but how will
you solve it by killing every human
being so that we don't have to create
any more carbon you don't want that kind
of solution right that's the simplistic
simple mind thing when you're saying
well solve this problem quickly no
that's evil AI That's the evil Ai No
that's the AI that doesn't know the
difference between good and evil exactly
the immoral AI the the amoral
aial so that's where that Frontier is I
believe Neil and Gary and Chuck it's the
issue of trying to make sure that we do
it right and do it safely so that
whatever AI doesn't ignore what we need
of it it's the other way around that we
worry about if a human is in charge of
AI and Quanto Computing go we tell
ourselves right yeah well let's let's go
with temporarily in charge that's what
you tell yourself about your cat yeah
I'm in charge of my cat yeah I mean yeah
never ever ever going to be the case so
the thing is someone's going to have
that immoral
attitude and steer that intelligence in
a certain direction there's not always
going to be captain goodat in charge of
AI
imoral believes that they are immoral
that's a whole other challenge that we
have there you go this becomes very
ethical the winners of Wars are those
who write the history books and so
that's how that goes and just to be
clear in case people didn't know you can
be moral or immoral amoral means you are
neither moral nor immoral that's right
um so that's that's it it just to be
clear people know how we use that term
and so chuck if you're an
a-hole either one kind of hole or
another right well no if you're an
a-hole we know exactly what kind of hole
you
are you know I will wrap up by saying
that Neil you actually know this much
better than I do um astronomers have
been using Ai and machine learning for
decades we have no fear of this material
we are perfectly understanding that this
can be used to do great things like help
us understand data from Millions ions of
stars and galaxies when a single human
being could do all that calculation at
once so it's not a matter of being
afraid of it or saying oh my gosh we
have to avoid it or oh my gosh we must
exploit it it's another mystery a puzzle
a tool that we can work with and we can
learn about and we can sick on our
unknowns in this world and if that fails
we all die okay that's there you go oops
we're all gonna
die well we'll all die eventually right
it's matter when and how yeah all right
guys char Charles it's always good to
have you it is such a pleasure to be
here everybody thank you so much for
having rejoining us and we know that
when we all visit your house we just say
where's the dumb one I want to talk to
that's gonna beat
you hands down hands down right Gary
always good to have you man pleasure my
friend and Chuck nice you are in AR Ruba
right now say hi to the Caribbean for us
all we'll do all right this has been
Star Talk special edition its own
version of cosm quaries a delight in its
complexity and its Joy especially
brought to us in the guys of Charles W
I'm Neil degrass Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking
[Music]
up